investigators in florida released body
camera footage of a wild shootout
between deputies and a boy and girl the
volusa county sheriff's office says the
children
shot at the deputies for more than half
an hour tuesday night before the
deputies returned fire
manuel bejorquez has more on this story
and we do warn you
the video is disturbing
shooting out the rear window toward my
direction stand by that sergeant donnie
maxwell taking
cover behind a tree
he's taking fire from a 12-year-old boy
and a 14-year-old girl from inside the
house
police say the two children had fled
from a juvenile home northeast of
orlando
and broken into this unattended house
finding several large firearms
when police arrived the children opened
fire
put the guns down
10-4 they're shooting at me at one point
in the nine-minute edited video
maxwell with his gun drawn mutters to
himself
appearing to pray for a peaceful outcome
don't let me do this
don't do this more than 30 minutes into
the standoff
aerial footage then appears to capture
police opening fire
the flashing dots are the bullets coming
from the officers assembled behind the
tree
police say they started shooting
striking the girl and wounding her
after she came outside pointing a
shotgun at the officers
the 12-year-old boy who had been
carrying an ak-47
surrenders and the officers rushed to
administer first aid to the girl
it up here now in the whoever none of
the officers were injured despite having
multiple rounds fired at them
but the female suspect was transported
to a local hospital
where she underwent surgery and is in
stable condition
in a statement the juvenile facility
where the children were staying said
these children are in desperate need of
care in the appropriate setting
which is a higher level of care than we
provide
for cbs this morning anwa bajorkas miami